now we have some news about paper chase
a statement from The Joint
administrators which trades as paper
chase Aspen Phoenix Nico limited saying
that unfortunately despite a
comprehensive sales process no viable
offers were received for the company or
its businesses and assets on a going
concern basis however there has been
significant interest in the paper chase
brand and attendant intellectual
property so the joint administrators
will continue trading the company's
operations in the short term with all
stores remaining open and trading as
normal and at present the company will
continue to honor gift cards but we'd
strongly urge customers to redeem them
as soon as possible they will not be
possible to do that after the next two
weeks so this is the news that paper
chase stalls are going to continue to
stay open gift cards will be honored for
the next two weeks but the joint
administrators will then continue to
monitor trading in the stores further
updates provided in due course so not
really a happy State of Affairs if
you're employed by paper chase or any of
its suppliers on the Sky News website
you will see an exclusive report from
our city editor Mark Kleinman from over
the weekend that Tesco is poised to snap
up the brand in a surprise swoop that
could cast a shadow of the hundreds of
High Street jobs so it seems that paper
chase is not closing today but it
doesn't look hopeful for it over the
next two weeks but we know that Tesco
does have an interest in perhaps buying
the brand